we felt like we did everything we had to
do and it's like at that point you know
it's like if it happens it happens and
the Oscar goes
to hair love Matthew a Harry and Ken
River I don't even remember how we got
on the stage we somehow got there just
magically um it was all just a dream you
dream about a moment like that all your
life when you're up there you're
literally looking at a crowd of I forget
how many thousand people were there in
cartoons that's when we first see our
movies and it's how I we shape our lives
and think about how we see the world
even though these characters in in our
short film were black there's just
something about the medium that really I
think just makes people a little bit
more open to exploring these worlds that
are a little bit more either Fantastical
or worlds that aren't what their normal
experience is I have to do something
just as good so I can get back there and
you know think him thank him
again